Dreams didn't make us Kings
dragons did
the greens are coming for you
rhaenyra and for your children
we don't choose our destiny it chooses us
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my new house of the dragon video I'll talk
about all the dragons because they're hyping
up a bunch of new dragons in the finale and
obviously we're going to see a bunch more during
season two there's gonna be 17 total during the
entire run of the series so I will explain who
all the dragons are who rides them because they
call them the dragon seeds and they're going to
be really big during season two we're going to
hear a little bit about them during episode 10
of the finale if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos I will
be doing house the dragon bonus videos during the
off season while we wait for season 2 to arrive
as well but the actual title of the episode is
the black queen because we're near aside in the
dance of the dragons is referred to as the blacks
because she's going to crown herself with her
father's Crown like you literally see Eric with
an e one of the twins hand the crown to her thank
you very much for bogarting that from the red keep
you can also see a faction of the kingsguard who
supports her who's still loyal to her who comes
to Dragonstone not all the kingsguard but some
of them they tease that during episode nine like
there's this big rift where some of them support
the greens and some of them still support rhaenyra
the reason why they call call them the blacks
and the greens is because of the colors of the
gallons that ranera and alicent typically wore
like they wore different types of gowns but they
typically wore the same colors of gowns there's
a much deeper meaning as to why renera always
wore black and why Alice and always wore green
I'll talk about that in my future videos like
my finale video as well but typically during the
actual dance itself when each faction is referring
to the other one or making battle plans or just
relaying information about the other faction they
refer to them as the greens or the blacks for the
most part this season the story is only focused
on the Core Family itself like the core nuclear
family with a few Side characters and distant
relatives Criston Cole and Harold westerling are
examples of important characters who are really
close to the story but not part of the actual
family even though I'm sure Criston Cole wishes
he was part of alicent's family we know what
you're thinking about there they very clearly
have some weird thing going on and even though she
had all the weird feet stuff going on with larys
strong it kind of sounds like she wasn't sleeping
around or anything like that like the worst thing
that she did was do the feed stuff with larys
strong and that was mostly because he was just
trying to prove to her how much power he had over
her like that was a big Power Play from him he
was getting off on that amongst other things he
was kind of getting off on the feet as well even
though both of the sides are going to be doing
very terrible things to each other's side you do
feel a little bit bad for alicent she's got all
this power but she's somehow the least powerful
person in this equation like she winds up losing
no matter how much the greens win to say nothing
of aegon II turning into like the next coming of
Joffrey even though technically this is earlier
in the timeline so technically Joffrey would be
more like him than him being more like Joffrey
the reason why I say the story is so focused
on the actual nuclear Royal Family itself is
one because of the whole Targaryen Civil War like
it's a war within their family but also because of
the Targaryen The Valyrian bloodline in the Dragon
Riders like yes this is all about the Iron Throne
all about the crown but it's all about the dragons
too so the whole idea is that we've been focusing
the story on the royal family it's up like the
nuclear family because they're all dragon riders
for the most part you have some velaryons who have
married into the family who aren't dragon riders
but like rhaenys for instance is a Targaryen
she's of Targaryen blood baela and rhaena are
velaryons technically but they're Daemon's
children so they're also Dragon Riders when
we actually spin up to big dragon battles in the
sky like we're talking season two stuff maybe a
little bit during episode 10. there are a ton more
people that become really important characters for
the story because they're either Dragon seeds or
close advisors to each faction small council like
the green council and raniero's black council and
that's what we mean when we say the dragonseeds,
dragonseeds are just people of Valyrian descent
either targaryens or velaryons or their bastards
from one of the houses who aren't technically
inside the line of succession but they still
have Valyrian blood they still have the gene
for riding dragons I think most of them will
meet during season two but they might tease some
of them during episode 10 just because there's so
much a story that they have to cover and they've
already teased so much in the trailer so far
but you get that voice over from Daemon in the
trailer saying dreams didn't make the Targaryen
Kings dragons did that's meant to flow with the
other dialogue during the battle planning meeting
when they say their faction wields a power that
hasn't been seen in Westeros since the time of
aegon the Conqueror in both those comments are
just references to the sheer quantity of dragons
that raniera's side has compared to the greens
currently at the start of the dance rhaenyra's
side controls about 14 or 15 dragons plus they
have access to a couple more dragon eggs there
are 10 members of the royal family all who have
their own dragons there's one velaryon bastard
called addam velaryon who rides sea smoke after
laenor velaryon the show might do something weird
with that character or they might not include
him or they might say that he's actually laenor
velaryon just using a fake name I'm a totally new
person I just happen to be riding the same dragon
as laenor velaryon nobody asks questions or look
at me too long and there are two new Targaryen
bastards who were born on Dragonstone that they
haven't introduced on the show yet one called
wolf white who rides Silverwing who used to belong
to alysanne Targaryen who was jaehaerys' wife and
the other being someone called Hugh Hammer who
winds up writing vermithor who we do see in the
trailers that's the giant dragon that Daemon
winds up summoning there are three other wild
dragons that they have access to as well but they
don't currently have riders for at the moment
like they're looking for as many Dragon Riders
as possible to support their side there's the
Sheepstealer who's written by Nettles eventually
there's cannibal who's written by someone called
Silver Denys and there's one other wild dragon
called gray ghost but neither faction in the
dance of the dragons winds up being able to claim
him so he just goes riderless through the entire
dance the reason why there are wild dragons to
begin with because you think well wouldn't you
actually want as many dragons to be ridden as
possible you have to remember that during the
time of jaehaerys even though he had tons of
kids most of them died either early deaths or
mysterious deaths way before their time so up
to this point there just haven't been that many
people of Valyrian descent there have been more
dragons than there have been people to ride them
because of what's happened with the dance of the
dragons and viserys getting remarried to alicent
and her having a whole litter of children and
then having some grandchildren on top of that
because of aegon II and Helaena's children in all
of Daemon's marriages and remarriages to renew and
all the extra children that they they wind up
having right now where we are in the timeline
there are more people of Valyrian descent who
are capable of riding dragons than in any other
time in history so basically during the dance you
just have their factions just looking for all the
riderless dragons like hey dragon come here we
need you for something really important you also
have a lot of people in the Targaryen bloodline
before this that just didn't have a lot of kids
or died early or mysterious devs thus all the
problems you have with the line of succession
and who winds up taking the Iron Throne there have
been a couple big battles maegor was another big
battle that got fought a long time ago as you
see in the trailer rhaenyra still riding Cyrax
you actually see a parallel for episode 2 when
she lands syrax on the bridge here getting ready
to fight the greens she's also wearing viserys's
crown when she does that too Daemon is also on the
bridge just like he was during episode 2 pulling
his sword on otto hightower just like they did
before Daemon obviously still writing caraxes even
though he's getting vermithor he doesn't wind up
writing Vermithor that winds up being someone
else jacaerys still rides Vermax lucerys rides
arrax who we see in the the trailer for the first
time getting ready to fight aemond at Storm's
End I'll talk about that in a second too Joffrey
Velaryon's dragon is called tyraxes her first son
with daemon aegon III winds up writing a dragon
called stormcloud her second son with daemon
viserys II has a dragon egg but obviously he's a
baby like he's too young to actually ride a dragon
rhaenys still has melees who we see in the trailer
getting ready to fly to one of the other Realms to
get one of the other Lords to support them Baela
is riding Moondancer and rhaena rides a dragon
called morning there is a lot of backstabbing
in betrayal during the dance of the Dragon so
like not everybody who fights for the blacks at
the beginning winds up fighting for them in the
end like people do switch sides during the actual
War but that's like over the course of a couple
seasons it's a lot like the war of the five Kings
with all the betrayal you have the whole idea of
the betrayal during the Red Wedding there's a
lot of that kind of stuff that goes on during
the dance of the dragons currently the greens only
control six dragons and all the dragon riders are
members of the core Royal nuclear family but
like I said there is some betrayal like some
Dragon Riders do eventually wind up switching size
throughout the many seasons of the show aegon II
still rides Sunfire really hoping that we get
to see Sunfire again before the finale is over
Helaena rides a dragon called dreamfyfre which
is ironic because she has Dragon dreams and she
writes a dragon called dreamfyre fun fact too
daenerys's dragon eggs also came from dreamfyre
that's why dreamfyre looks a lot like daenerys's
dragons aemond Targaryen obviously rides vhagar,
daeron targaryen who is a character that they
didn't use during season one that much but he is
around he's alicent's fourth child with viserys
he's supposed to be like a page inside King's
Landing somewhere else during the events of season
one we'll see him during season two he rides a
dragon called tessarion they did show his symbol
in the intro though just to let you know oh he's
alive we'll do him eventually aegon and helaena's
two children here are jaehaerys and jaehaera
both have dragons jaehaerys rides a dragon called
shrykos and jaehaera rides a dragon called morghul
their third child maelor does have a dragon
egg though we haven't seen the third child yet
but the third child is also represented in the
intro like there's a third symbol here meaning
that it does exist it is alive and even though
they're hyping up jakaris going to Winterfell
to try and win over house Stark which sounds
like they're going to declare for renera really
cool to see the Starks come back into the story I
think most of the action of the trailer is focused
on Storm's End with this big rematch between
aemond and lucerys the big thing about this is
that lucerys has this tiny dragon like arrax is
tiny compared to vhagar so he'd have no chance
if vhagar got his claws into him the big advantage
that the smaller dragons have is that they're way
faster than the bigger older dragons and way more
maneuverable so that's why you see them flying all
over the place in this giant storm like it's
called the stormlands for a reason so it'll be
like an elephant attacking a mouse and obviously
lucerys has no desire to fight his cousin like he
doesn't have bloodlust in him like he doesn't live
for chaos the way that it seems like aemond does
regardless of what their history is like clearly
he doesn't hate aemond but daemond is just itching
to get revenge for losing his eye to lucerys when
they were younger that's why it looks like he rips
off his eye patch to show luceris his Sapphire
I like see what you did to me that's also why
aemond's symbol so in the intro is represented by
the sapphire to represent his Sapphire eye so the
big threat here is that even though lucerys has
no desire to actually fight aemond aemond loves
craves fighting I am sure the episode will be just
as heart-wrenching and WTF as you would expect but
it will fully be an eye for an eye like make all
the references to eyes that you want during their
big fight scene the big idea though that before
everybody claims all their support from all these
different lords different Realms declare for
each side rhaenyra size seems like it has the
advantage because they have so many more dragons
than the greens but remember things change really
fast it will literally be a battle royale my
full episode 10 finale video will post sunday
after they release it and then I'll start doing
more bonus videos for season two after the finale
actually comes out if you have any big questions
or anything I didn't address during this video
just write it below in the comments and I'll try
to add it to my bonus videos in my finale video
it is going to be crazy in the best possible way
everyone click here for my episode 10 video I'll
update the link as soon as I post that and click
here for for all my other house of the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!